die passagiere an bord der challenger
604 haben wollen mit dem tod gerechnet
und wäre der unfall etwas tiefer gesehen
wäre es wohl auch zu dieser katastrophe
kommen innerhalb von 30 sekunden
sturzflug knapp 3000 meter in die tiefe
und schuld daran waren airbus a380 wie
das ganze passieren konnte und warum der
airbus a380 so gefährlich ist jetzt
wirklich zum tragen sind herzlich
willkommen
das war für die passagiere wirklich eine
absolute katastrophe und in viel kleiner
maßstab passiert das immer wieder
flugzeuge fliegen durch die
wirbelschleppen eines anderen flugzeugs
selber hat das einmal erlebt und es
versetzt viele passagiere in panik es
ist ein ziemlicher knall und es fühlt
sich an wie ein ziemlich tiefes
schlagloch in einer straße rum
was jetzt aber hier passiert ist war
mehr als ein knaller diesen zwischenfall
wurde eine challenger 604 ein privatjet
komplett zerstört was war passiert jedes
flugzeug zieht sogenannte
wirbelschleppen hinter sich her dass in
bürgel am ende der flügel die die luft
hinter dem flugzeug gefällig erwerben so
dass andere flugzeuge einen gewissen
abstand einheiten müssen weil sie in
diesen bürgern ja mit gewirbelt werden
je größer und schwerer ein flugzeug ist
desto größer und gefährlicher sind auch
die wirbelschleppen der airbus a380 ist
das grösste und schwerste
verkehrsflugzeug er bog in diesem fall
520 tonnen an flughäfen muss deshalb
zwischen den flugzeugen ein deutlicher
abstand bei start und landung
eingehalten werden
je größer das flugzeug desto größer der
nötige abstand um eben nicht mit gewerbe
zu werden aber genau dieses mit wirbel
es geschah jetzt der flugverkehr ist in
so genannte flug flächen aufgeteilt wie
haben einen abstand von rund 300 metern
also 1000 fuß und je nach flug fläche
fliegen die maschinen in westliche und
östliche richtungen wird die gefahr von
zusammenstößen deutlich reduziert
genauso war es auch hier die beiden
maschinen begegneten sich auf zwei
übereinander liegenden flug flächen und
flogen in entgegengesetzten richtungen
also alles nach lehrbuch
doch dieses mal passierte etwas das dann
so in keinem lehrbuch 68 sekunden
nachdem der airbus a380 die challenger
604 passiert hatte war seine
wirbelschleppen die flugbahn des
privatjets abgesagt wurde geschah genau
das was an flughäfen befürchtet wird die
challenger wurde durch den wirbel drei
bis fünfmal so genau weiß das keiner
mehr um die eigene achse gewirbelt alle
luftströmungen rissen ab und das
flugzeug flog nicht mehr es stürzte ab
die passagiere wurden durch das flugzeug
gewirbelt und nur durch ein wunder wurde
niemand schwer verletzt
jetzt stürzt die maschine aber
ungebremst richtung boden 30 lange
sekunden 2700 meter tief dann erst
konnte der pilot die maschine ab
danach war ein triebwerk überhitzt und
die gesamte struktur des flugzeugs so
schwer belastet worden
dass es lima fliegen darf totalschaden
aber was sind die konsequenzen müssen
die flughäfen größere abstände haben
wird der luftraum damit kleiner und kann
weniger geflogen werden wir halten euch
hier auf dem laufen nicht verpassen und
mehr hier ein abo aufs auge drücken
nicht vergessen mir einen auf die glocke
zu geben
nur dann werdet ihr über jedes neue
video informiert hier geht es für den
besten videos von klicks um umwegen
draufklicken und staunen und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran